on sunday when drew locke exited for the
broncos and it began to look like he may
miss some time i pulled up the roster
looked at the depth chart looked at the
practice squad i saw two other
quarterbacks jeff driscoll
and brett rippon
and it was pretty clear that if drew
lock was going to miss some time they
would need some help and there aren't
many guys out there and i allowed myself
to think for a second or two that maybe
the guy who's been waiting for a phone
call yes a phone call yeah for three and
a half years would get one he didn't
your guy blake bortles did the man who
was not put on earth to throw a football
as you have said repeatedly that's your
word not mine i don't want to get any
more angry emails from anybody who are
in the blake bortles fan club but blake
bortles gets the job site on scene colin
kaepernick continues to wait and you
know i saw someone explain yesterday
well you know they wanted to sign him
last year well it was a different
offensive coordinator last year so i
mean so what if they were interested
last year they were interested in colin
kaepernick five years ago i mean he did
but but the bottom line is bortles was
available for a reason he was on no
one's 80 man roster or 90 man for the
teams that had 90 right and went through
all the final cuts and his name was
never even mentioned it wasn't until
this drew lock injury that blake bortles
comes back and that's fine that's their
prerogative look i'm done i'm
you know the acceptance phase the colin
kaepernick it's over it's done and i
think this blake bortle
signing by the broncos is just simply
another last nail in the coffin yeah it
is it really is there's no doubt i mean
bortles is a fortunate situation for him
because the broncos are one of those
situations where you know like you said
you look at the roster and you go oh man
yeah they don't have much there it's
just those two guys and then it's a lot
of unproven commodities that no coach or
gm in their right mind's gonna go oh
well hey we'll roll the dice and let him
be the backup this week you know jeff
driscoll could get hurt first drive high
ankle sprain and all of a sudden you're
going whoa you know we got a young guy
like ripon who was on the practice squad
last week out here in the game or
whatever it may be so that's why they
needed blake bortles for just in case
driscoll gets hurt they gotta have a guy
that at least has like played nfl
football knows how to like run an
offense get in and out of the huddle do
those type of things
so i think that's where the value of
bortles is here just more or less that
being able to execute offense been in a
few different ones so he'll be able to
pick it up you know fairly fairly
quickly
and yeah blake is not a guy you know
that is put under earth to throw the
football he is big he's got some
leadership and he's a good athlete
and at the very worst they'll have to
figure something out with that type of
skill set but yeah i don't expect him to
be in there to beat jeff driscoll out or
anything like that driscoll played well
last week very very well
how telling is it that the rams signed
bortles last year says it all the backup
to jared goff and they let his contract
lapse
and there was never a conversation never
a discussion never an inkling about
bringing him back doesn't that look and
i'm sorry to anyone out there that is is
in the black bortles fan club as small
as it may be but doesn't that tell us
everything pretty much it does yes i i i
think that is like the ultimate writing
is on the wall sean mcvay quarterback
whisperer offensive genius
you know there they are with the team
the right you know the year after the
super bowl here we are two years after
the super bowl they went in another
direction with a guy that's
an unproven commodity too this year to
be a backup quarterback and just said
that
so yeah they obviously didn't love what
they saw from blake bortles that's where
you know he's not the perfect backup in
the world as we know because he's not
going to come out just throwing balls
all over the field and doing that that's
not what he is he's never been about
that
and uh yeah it's he wouldn't be my
backup that's all i'm saying
who would you have picked between
bortles and kaepernick or is that a
stupid question well it's it's not a
stupid i mean there's no question
between the talent and things like that
but again i think even for a guy like me
who loved colin kaepernick and was was
saying at one point he was one of the
five best quarterbacks in football i
just would be you know
scared to death that he it's been that
long he hasn't played and it's just not
that easy to get back out there and play
football or even get into the practice
mode when you haven't been around it
especially at quarterback it's different
there so i understand them going with
bortles just because of the experience
and he's been around and doing those
type of things and he's not a
distraction but uh the talent the pure
talent that's not even close
yeah i mean bortles hasn't done anything
all year either no you're right bortles
is in you're right the last time he was
with the team was week 17 of last year
that's right deployment after that all
the way until yesterday yeah and one
quick history lesson for those of you
out there who are inclined to traffic in
the colin kaepernick false narratives
because one of them is that the broncos
were interested in him after he became a
free agent and he said no thank you that
is just not i hear that everywhere it
actually drives me crazy it's become the
story and it's not real
and here's the thing and this is a line
that dee smith used during the lockout
in 2011 you're entitled your own
opinions you're not entitled to your own
facts these are the facts and they are
undisputed it was in 2016 when the 49ers
were considering moving on from colin
kaepernick because his contract was 12
million dollars and it was guaranteed at
that point because he had three
different injuries that required surgery
they couldn't cut him before the start
of the league year or more accurately
april 1 when his contract became
guaranteed for skill injury and cap and
they had the 12 million on the books so
they looked into trading him the broncos
were very interested in trading for
colin kaepernick that was after peyton
manning retired and brock osweiler
defected for the texans so the broncos
were interested but what they wanted to
do was to get colin kaepernick to take
less than the 12 million he was fully
entitled to and he said no thank you and
that's when the trade fell through and
there's a postscript to this because
then in 2017 when he was a free agent
without a 12 million guaranteed salary
with no real leverage at all and no one
interested john elway's position on
kaepernick was well he had his chance
last year that's why we're not
interested in him this year meanwhile
after brock osweiler was the subject of
the hot potato trade that sent him from
the texans of the browns and the browns
cut him and the broncos needed another
quarterback they signed osweiler even
though osweiler stuck his finger in
their eye in free agency the year
earlier you can't make this stuff up
chris no you cannot and that is the
story you're right it's it's amazing how
the stories become paraphrased and that
yes somehow it's calcified
and
he's the one that had the chance to sign
with the denver broncos and didn't do it
and that's just not the way it went down
but that's the world we live in right
now there's there is the facts and then
there's the story that people like to
tell themselves so they feel good that
aren't the facts but they just feel good
i guess about it i don't know
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports